así es hubo tres protestas durante esta
jornada una de esas protestas fue una
manifestación callejera en el centro de
la ciudad de la paz estas personas
estaban protestando porque consideran
que hubo un fraude electoral ellos
fueron dispersados por la policía con
gases lacrimógenos también hubo una
protesta dentro del hemiciclo donde juró
luis arse la bancada de comunidad
ciudadana del ex presidente carlos mesa
ha exhibido unos carteles pidiendo que
el movimiento al socialismo restituía
los dos tercios de votos que han sido
eliminados de los reglamentos de las
cámaras legislativas luego de hacer esa
protesta la bancada de comunidad
ciudadana ha abandonado el hemiciclo
antes de que ar se emita su discurso y
por otro lado hubo otra en santa cruz
por parte de los parlamentarios de
creemos de luís fernando camacho ellos
han decidido quedarse en su región
presentarse en la plaza central de
santacruz y no asistir a la toma de
posesión de luisa arse mary cuales
podríamos considerar como los puntos
principales del discurso de asunción de
luis arse
yo dividiría el discurso en dos partes
la primera parte que abarcó más o menos
la mitad es decir 15 minutos estuvo
orientada a responsabilizar al gobierno
de jeanine áñez de todo lo malo que pasó
en el país en los últimos 11 meses por
ejemplo la triple crisis económica
política y sanitaria pero también una
crisis de la democracia se ha acusado a
años de haber mutilado la democracia de
haber perseguido a los dirigentes del
más y haber provocado la muerte de
ciudadanos en las revueltas del año
pasado y la segunda parte del discurso
le llamaríamos el discurso de la
esperanza pues luis ar se ha prometido
sacar al país de estas tres crisis y
también ha aprovechado para delinear su
política exterior ha dicho que bolivia
piensa apostar por la celac y además
reactivar la unasur ha dicho que apuesta
por la cooperación sur-sur y por un
mundo multipolar y qué información
maneja almería acerca del regreso de evo
morales al país que se prevé que eso sea
mañana lunes y esto recordemos tras
haber permanecido casi un año asilado en
argentina
lo que sabemos es que evo morales- y ha
abandonado buenos aires y que se
encuentra en la ciudad norteña de jujuy
donde va a pasar la noche y mañana
alrededor de las 10 de la mañana va a
cruzar la frontera desde la quiaca en
territorio argentino hasta villazón en
territorio boliviano acompañado por el
presidente argentino alberto fernández
ahí se va a hacer un acto de despedida
por parte de fernández para evo morales
y luego morales junto a sus seguidores
va a emprender una caravana que según
dicen tiene inscritos unos 800 vehículos
para llegar hasta el chapare de donde él
es el dirigente máximo de los cocaleros
el acto central del chapare está
previsto para el día 11 es decir justo
el mismo día en el que el año pasado él
tuvo que salir al exilio desde ese lugar
chimoré en el chapare de cochabamba